in this capsule we will see the rule
from the separations that will us
to identify independence
conditional then the rule of
separation it's a rule that is
general that will allow us
to identify any
conditional independence of gender if
I have a node x so we go there
determine if these donors are
independent and give a number of
hours 10 hours until z
m any and died road that the
number of us on which I condition
could be zero in any
would condition on the empty set so
we would condition on none would
so checking a
normal independence and not come
conditional dependence so the arrival
separations that will allow us to
identify it these water independences
in any case for any
which network beziers and we see between
other than that it is obvious that the
three examples we saw a capsule
previous ones are going to be cases
finally that they are beautiful
and well identified by the rule of
separation then the way that works
this rule is that we are going to say that x
va was dependent on y sacha z
if all the paths not directed during
days and I mean to all
paths between nodes 2 x 2 y that do not
do not necessarily respect the meaning
arrows so xy my independence
shopping and knowing did
if all the paths not directed between aix
and z are blocked by two nodes
helpers and so we have to determine how
what a path becomes blocked and
this part one that often not very
intuitive among others the rule from here to
which I ask you to wear a
special attention but so we go
say that a path is blocked if at least
we will call end who will satisfy
any of the following conditions
the condition in the condition of
so there must be an en
be and 1 hour with arrow in 30
followed by an outgoing arrow
or who is an egg with two arrows
outgoing which is such that n belongs to
my set of variables z is so
marked in fact that it's both
first examples that we treated the
previous capsule where we have a big
parent a parent who would be aisne then
a child hockey and that's the second
where we made a parent with two
children
here it's that kind of us there and in this
case we have that the path is blocked if
n is observed then in the same way
in the previous capsules we saw that
we did have dependence between
e here an eye here where we read here or here
if the parent in question were
observed so that's the first rule
are found a place that is satisfied that
the path is stuck at this zero to and the
second possibility this is actually
a place where we have two incoming arrows
so that's the case where we stop two
parents here who are pointing to the same
child or between the child and the dance that
if the new being stuck at n 6 n
does not belong to the observed variable
none of the descendants of m
so it must not only she
does not belong to all
variables and teens up to zm who are
observed but also all
descendants of hatred do not have to
hold this together they noticed
that a particular case is still
would only have 3 we got two by
hour then a child and as in
the example we saw and both parents
are independent only if she
does not belong to z and the subtlety or
the more general aspect we add
is that its a serious that more than 3
knots it is also necessary that the
descendants of hatred do not belong
to z who we look at some examples
the application of the rule of
separations
first example in a new network
bezian that we see here that is the kind
network of beziers to make
medical diagnosis
so is the variable or the new
age and gender are independent a priori
so in this case it's the crucible of
the empty set then what one has to
to do is to identify all the paths
in the hands not directed to angie
gender and determine if they are blocked
by a place on the way then a
first path is the path that leaves
hedge enters into smoking then so
way here and there between gender because
if the path is a single draw it is the no
tuxedo which is an honor with two
arrows in 30
then is the path blocked
know us there well since smoking here
wages that are 15 hours and then
calcium is long all hand so
what do these four knots do there
are not observed sadek belong
not at all obviously aims
actually this way is blocked
so the first way the way that
goes through smoking is stuck honor
tuxedo which is a place with flash
footprints and with two arrows hinders
there is a second way the one that
goes through total exposure 6 and who passes
then by ken goes back to smoking and
arrived gender in this case we still have
once a wall with arrows to
get into that if it's the knot
cancer 'here only two arrows in train
on the way and for the same reasons
to say that nikon sony his descendants
belong to the empty set which
the set of variables observe so
that no variables observed for these
same reasons the beautiful honor 15h
block their way this folder this
second path exists no other
way and gender and so we have him
even showed that all paths are
blocked and so the answer is that yes
and I have gender are independent
a priori second example we have been
long color will know if his
independence his luck mocking age and
surround him here know if they are
independent sacha smoking first
way between h and the next day it's the
path that we see here so that goes through
tuxedo then who goes to canes on who
happens above all but in this case
can we block the path
we can look at one hour
tuxedo no smoking is a place that
in arrow in 30 that an outgoing arrow
so a big umbrella a child and
tuxedos and observe and for this type of
here we here the rule to block the
way is that the hand must be
observed so the path is well and truly
second path block the one that goes through
the one who goes through traffic explosion
this cancer 'that happens are all going
die then in this case we can
to watch is it stuck to
exposure of the toxic her naked breasts with
incoming and outgoing flash
actually here we have incoming arrow
followed by an outgoing arrow and for the
block it must be observed
but expose all toxic it's not
observed only tuxedo who
then observed in the same way that a
only who is also a knot with arrow
get in flash coming out so answer is
managed to observe you soon as smoking
which is observed and therefore the path is
no more stuck at cancer level '
so because of that the way of the
second way is not blocked and
so help and their moods are not
independent sacha tuxedo third and
last example is what exposure to
take 6 and tuxedos his independence h1
and joe
identify the paths so we have a
way first path that goes through edu
and then who came smoking like that so
here we can block the path only
at a place to edge it's an art with
two outgoing flashes and the queen we
says that to block this is there you have to
that the north issue be observed edge
and eddy actually observed so the
blocked way second way then one
could reach smoking from a
exposed toxic through ken sure
like this and here now the name in
question her naked breasts with an arrow
in thirty-one others the cantor in
helping what if the rule applies
it is the judgment that says that the
node or his descendants is not
observed by cons so one does not go
block this way there because among these
descendants there is love to me so
it's a descendant of caine sisters here
but rumor him and observe so at
because of that we can not block their
way to this part of the because we do not
can not block it at 3 pm there is
no other no one in this way there the
way two years you exposed or toxic
and tuxedos and so because of that the
path must not block so one more
times here we only have exposure to toxic
and tuxedos are not independent
Sasha and slowly